top health officials testifying on
capitol hill today
democrats desperately trying to get them
to criticize president trump's pandemic
response
but they wouldn't take the bait and this
moment from congressman jim jordan and
dr anthony fauci getting a lot of
attention
take a look i don't judge one crowd
versus another crowd
when you're in a crowd particularly if
you're not wearing a mask
that is this is simple it's a simple
question doctor should we limit the
protest
i don't know how many times i can answer
that i'm not going to opine on limiting
anything i'm just going to tell you
you've behind on a lot of things dr
powell yeah but i've never this is
something that directly impacts the
spread of the virus and i'm asking your
your position on the protest yeah i said
crowds
i didn't say specifically i didn't say
protest to anything so the protests
don't increase the spread of the
violence i didn't say that you're
putting words in my mouth
jesse i'd like to start with you so in
rooting against trump
are we seeing democrats here blurring
the lines between
cheering on his perceived
administration's failures
and cheering on the virus well i think
that's a perception among some people
but man
falcio's had a tough stretch i mean
first the wild first pitch
then getting grilled by jim jordan i
would not want to be
getting grilled by jim jordan that guy
is tenacious and i think he proved a
pretty solid point that listen
we know fouchy's a democrat we know he's
a very smart
guy and he's doing the best he can but
he seems like he's playing favorites
sometimes you're like
why can't he just call it a protest why
rhetorically does he have to
make the distinction that it's just a
crowd because going to church
and protesting still covered under the
first amendment they should be
treated equally and he his opined on a
number of things
dating he's opined on sports reopening
school's reopening travel
businesses he's done a lot of opining
and then for him to not want to opine
on black lives matter protests just
seems like
i just don't know whether he's he's
calling balls and strikes
that's my point but but the fact that
fouchy is
is a political pinata at this point
makes me feel like things are getting
back to normal a little bit
at least we can all hope
dana were you going to say something
yeah i just
so we started this segment by saying
that fauci wouldn't take the democrats
bait
to dis the trump administration and in
fact
praise the trump administration's
coronavirus response
but then he doesn't take the bait with
jim jordan
and then that's not good i think that
the point he was making is that he's
just not
taking the bait he's trying to be
professional he knew he was going to get
baited into talking about protests
and he didn't want to we talked about he
was trying to make a distinction about
crowds
so that he can maintain his credibility
as a public health person across the
board now if i were the republicans
if i had the headline that fouchy
redf redfield and jarrar all say
and praise the trump coronavirus
response i would have left it at that
because that would be the headline
that i would have wanted to leave this
hearing with because that's what
you know that's what the democrats
didn't want the democrats called the
hearing
and they got the headline that they
didn't want i would have just left it at
that
so greg taking that a step further then
this was supposed to be a solutions
focused hearing right
and then as always it devolves into a
partisan exercise
is this just going to get worse as we
head toward the general election
well first i would like to apologize uh
to dana preno
uh for making that my little pony
reference to her shirt
i realized that it's more like an at i
realized that it's more like an
advertisement for a fruit stripe gum
and so uh oh good good one
a good one i um
i thought that's why i only wear black
you know um a fruit stripe is the best
gum ever and they i don't even know if
they make it anymore
all right focus here's we were talking
about solutions and this is the thing
why i hate about hearings
we we've been hearing out right now i
always wonder
if we didn't televise the hearings would
all of these people
actually get stuff done because what
happens is it seems like they're all
auditioning
to be on a cable talk show they're all
like i'm gonna really
zing this guy and make him look stupid
and then i and then i'm going to have a
really funny joke and remember that
woman that
came up with that horrible joke about
baron trump it's because she knew she
was on tv
and so what tv does is it turns into
this hyper drama
and you actually don't hear about
solutions and i keep saying i said this
yesterday in a
a fleeting thought there's a lot of
stuff that's staying open
you're talking about places like lowe's
but you're also talking about day care
centers
so why can't we get data on the on
illnesses
or spread of illnesses from those places
and see how effectively they keep people
safe especially daycare centers because
you don't hear
you don't hear a lot about that and i'm
really curious we could get a lot of
really innovative ideas and
get them out there to the classrooms and
that would be a good thing
especially for kids who like to wear
colorful sweaters
[Laughter]
so one uh taking a couple points that
dana just made
is it possible for democrats to
acknowledge where this administration
has succeeded
in their response like for example we
know that joe biden came out and talked
about four things he would do
differently and this administration had
actually
worked on all four of those things so
there seems to be a disconnect
between that acknowledgement and what's
coming out of democrats mouths and
certainly what we saw today in the
hearing
i think i must have heard joe biden a
little differently emily i think he was
pretty clear
on steps that he would have taken
including you know making sure that the
hospitals had all the equipment they
needed
being much more aggressive about uh
tracing and the like
early on and not downplaying uh the
severity of the virus so i think that's
what joe biden said and i think it's
clear it's like two-thirds of americans
now
uh disapprove of president trump's
handling but
it the the question i think on the table
is about
protest and fouchy and so i was thinking
about this and
what strikes me is this that in a state
like florida where the president is
today we've seen
florida today set a record in terms of
covet deaths
a single day record they didn't have the
big protests places like new york
chicago
l.a had big protests uh dc here where i
live
and guess what within the 14-day
expanse of time when people say you're
going to see an uptick in the virus it
didn't happen
but now we're seeing outbreaks in places
where there wasn't
a lot of protesting over black lives
matter
and i think that uh it's kind of old
school at this point think oh yeah the
protests were going to be the problem
that hasn't proven to be the problem
that's a fact at this point
i can i just say one thing i want to
just mention something that juan said if
joe biden said he would have gotten the
ppe to the hospitals
faster was that ppe coming from the
stockpile that he left
empty with barack obama was that the ppe
they they
let it let go offshore to china
and do nothing about you are i just
don't understand how
the hospital jesse this is like jesse
this reminds me of trump the trump
administration saying oh
the obama administration left the
cupboard beer
there was no report no plan for dealing
all right we have to go you guys
unfortunately and just one to your point
remember however a whole burst of
national guardsmen
were infected with the coronavirus and
for portland
they're still on day 60 of protesting so
i don't think we know quite yet
what those ramifications are all right
moving on